yeah let's do a little monday night
football it was a big night last night
it's like we get off the plane all of a
sudden there's a monday night game on
let's go there washington in seattle
kind of a funny thing when we were
taking off you know when we were getting
out of baltimore we're sitting there on
the tarmac i'm going that's russell
wilson's airplane right there russell
wilson's plane was sitting right there
on the tarmac the r-dub and i'm going
why is russell wilson's playing there
they were playing in dc dc and baltimore
happened to be pretty close so let's
listen in as ross takes the l against
the washington football team here's some
of the sound right after the win
next time
[Applause]
everything we need is in this room
everybody in this room we need we've got
to work together stay together and be
the team that we can be
we will not take it from anybody i don't
give how they stack it against us we're
whipping
now let's play football everybody take
them all three one two three
that's pretty awesome how do you how do
you hear that how do you see that
celebration there rob
man that's what i'm talking about and
the washington football team will always
have an opportunity to win because they
got a good defense they can run the
football and they got a veteran coach
that understands those players in the
locker room ron rivera is a super bowl
champ 85 bears he's been there he's done
that he knows exactly what it takes i am
pumped up about everything that's going
on
and taylor heineke is a competitor i
mean i remember back to the the game
against the bucks in the playoffs last
year it's really how he earned this
opportunity to go compete for the job
he's just a competitor he's one of those
guys just going to leave it out there i
think he gives you enough opportunities
clearly to win the game and like your
mention they got this great running game
i thought they just out physically
outwilled
even the pass rush they were getting
some big shots on russell wilson in this
game but taylor heineke to me is just
one of those competing guys that's
always gonna give you a chance look at
this right here beat the pass rush beat
two guys go make that throw on the
sidelines some guys just have that
factor and he seems to have something
about that to his game rob what do you
what do you see it from heineken
i look at i look at
the skilled players around them they got
some really good skill players around
antonio gibson he showed us something
different i mean he came back he was
running harder he was running faster
logan thompson thomas is a big tight end
big athletic tight end love him
terry mclaren this is a kid that has had
several different quarterbacks he's
never complained he's never you know
said oh my goodness i gotta go with this
quarterback that quarterback he just
continues to go out there and plays he's
one of the best young receivers in the
game they have a really good offense
they got some weapons on the defensive
side of the ball those big boys up front
washington football team with that
experience head coach could go some
places obviously they still got to deal
with the dallas cowboys
that game with dallas looking a whole
lot more interesting at this point
washington is in the playoffs right now
the washington football team hanging on
to a playoff spot
and this is this is a team in seattle
that i'm used to being as you take a
look at the nfc playoff picture but
you're used to seattle being tougher and
grittier than most opponents especially
get them in prime time you're not used
to seeing sort of the fight being taken
out of that pete carroll defense but i
thought that was what washington did
even that that touchdown drive the way
they're moving them off the line in that
run game and then the two-point
conversion they go right back to just
hammering it they were hitting some huge
plays on screens on running back screens
in this game
really an impressive performance as
riverboat ron rivera out coaches pete
carroll which was pretty amazing to go
ahead and watch
i think it's a time i think it's time
for a change in seattle whether that's
russell wilson or whether that's pete
carroll it's not working out you look at
russell wilson he did not look happy and
everybody knows this off season he
wanted out of
seattle he wanted out of seattle he did
he want no part of being in seattle and
when you watch him and as a quarterback
he says we have to do a better job of
getting dk metcalf the ball you're a guy
that makes over 30 million dollars a
year
you have the utmost respect in that
locker room and you mean to tell me as
the quarterback of the seattle seahawks
you can't you cannot make an adjustment
and tell dk metcalf to run a bubble
screen a slant a quick out a comeback
something that gets him involved in the
game you don't want a talent like that
over there pouting on the sideline
rolling his eyes and talking negative to
other players because now that's
dissension within the locker room you
don't want that russell wilson needs to
be a better job of stop thinking about
himself and start thinking about the
team and getting his playmakers the ball
that's when they're at their very best
and
and obviously they have to find a run
game i think he had two rushes for like
16 yards and he was the leading rusher
you have to be able to run the football
you can't be one dimensional we see
what's going on with buffalo
yeah yeah and it how does it take until
the very last series that game you know
potentially game tying drive they needed
the two-point conversion on top of it
but that was the first catch that we saw
dk metcalf get i mean to your point
there's so many easy ways to get a
freight train like kim the ball end
around little screen quick out take a
shot just throw one up to them for it to
be all the way until the fourth quarter
before you even get them a touch and it
was an easy little out route touch
that's a mistake and that's how you end
up losing football games they don't have
enough playmakers to not get their best
the ball
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports